a dozen russian intelligence officers
indicted by special counsel robert
muller for cyber attacks during the 2016
presidential campaign the targets of the
hackers alleged allegedly included
Democratic Party groups its national and
congressional campaign committees as
well as the Hillary Clinton campaign the
indictment alleges that on July 27th
2016 hackers attempted to access Hillary
Clinton's personal accounts the
president was briefed on the indictments
earlier this week but a few hours before
the indictments were announced publicly
President Trump spoke about the Muller
investigation yeah I call it the rigged
witch-hunt I think that really hurts our
country and it really hurts our
relationship with Russia I think that we
would have a chance to have a very good
relationship with Russia and a very good
chance a very good relationship with
President Putin soon after mr. Trump met
with the Britons with Britain's Queen
Elizabeth at Windsor Castle the
president said he plans to ask Putin
about the meddling when they meet for a
summit in Helsinki Finland on Monday
here with more is CBS news political
correspondent ed O'Keefe he's in our
Washington bureau ed good morning good
morning guys so this comes just before
that Helsinki visit with with mr. Putin
as we mentioned what do you think mr.
Muller is trying to get across do you
think there is a motive behind the
timing of this release well the deputy
attorney general Rosenstein said
yesterday that this had more to do with
the fact that they had the evidence and
it was time to issue the indictments and
he pointed out that he had briefed the
president before he left for Europe
about these charges but I think whether
or not it was intentional it definitely
puts the onus now on the president to
bring this up somehow during his meeting
with the Russian president in Helsinki
would he ask him to please extradite
those 12 Russian military officials does
he say to him that you've got to
demonstrate that you are not meddling in
the midterm elections right now or does
he try to extract some other kind of
assurance that this won't happen again
and if he doesn't what kind of a
political price could he pay back here
in the United States for not doing so
that remains to be seen
the
president personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani tweeted Friday the Russians are
nailed know Americans are involved but
in fact unnamed Americans are mentioned
in this indictment are they not that's
right there's a congressional candidate
who we're still trying to sort out who
exactly that is there are others that
they came into contact with Justice
Department officials said Friday that
while no Americans were in died today in
this situation they definitely came in
to the Russians that are indicted came
into contact with Americans and they
made clear that at least in these
indictments there's no American that
leaves the door open to the possibility
that at some other point other Americans
will be indicted for being included or
working with Russians on their attempted
meddling and also the indictment
indicates that that Russia may have
acted when candidate Trump called for
the Hillary Clinton emails those
campaign emails at the time what's the
impact of that statement statement that
then candidate Trump made yeah so this
takes us back to June 2016 when it when
the summer 2016 when the president
now president candidate Trump said
something to the effect of Russians if
you're out there go after her emails
while the indictment shows that on or
about that exact date is when they first
tried to do this that's just their
stated as fact and they're not trying to
infer anything whether we learn in the
coming weeks or months however that
there that there was a direct lineage
between that statement and their attempt
to do this remains to be seen and that
is why the White House should remain
concerned that despite the fact that
this only involved Russians this week
remember there there are other ongoing
investigations into Paul Manafort into
Michael Flynn Michael Cohen the
president's personal attorney is now
caught up in this Roger stone his
longtime friend has been in touch with
the investigators there may be other
people out there that we just don't know
about the the the investigation and the
Russian meddling continues but there are
so many other aspects of this that they
continue to investigate that we still
don't know about and there was a
Washington Post Shara school poll that
indicated that this week that the
country is nearly split in half over the
special counsels investigation mostly
along party lines but what kind of
impact will this have if it goes on
really the question is how much time
does Muller have
well mother says he will take as long as
it takes for him regardless of the
potential political fallout but in the
meantime you will continue to see the
president supporters do whatever they
can to continue driving down that number
that that that level of support for the
investigation certainly among
Republicans if not among everyone that's
partly why that contentious hearing this
past week at the Capitol with that FBI
agent who had sent those texts about the
president was held at all not
necessarily just to question him but
also to use the venue to raise doubts
about the ongoing investigation to
question whether or not there aren't any
other bad actors in there and then drive
down support and and and and assurance
that this is a reputable investigation
the more that his supporters can do that
before the investigation is final the
more they believe they'll be able to
discredit it once it's all over you know
you look at the length there and you
compare it to things like whitewater and
iran-contra and obviously some
differences and some time still left
there ed O'Keefe in Washington Thank You
ed take care
CBS News coverage of the Trump Putin
summit in Helsinki starts tomorrow
morning on Face the Nation coverage
continues Monday on CBS this morning as
well as on CBS n our streaming service
and on the CBS Evening News with Jeff
Glor